ام
[موسيقى]
في صبيحه الخامس والعشرين من يناير كانون
الثاني لعام الفين واحد عشر
وكانت الشرطه المصريه قد اكملت
استعداداتها
للاحتفال بعيدها في الوقت الذي انتشرت فيه
دعوات على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تدعو
المصريين الى نزول الشوارع اعتراضا على
القهر الشرطي الذي فاق حدود الاحتمال
في الثامن والعشرين من يناير كانت مصر على
موعد مع تاريخ جديد حيث خرج المصريون الى
الساحات والميادين في انحاء البلاد كافه
اعتراضا على استعداد النظام ومشروع
التوريث
وخرجت قوات الشرطه والامن المركزي بكامل
طاقتها لمواجهه الشعب
في خلفيه هذا المشهد بدات حالات هروب
جماعي من السجون في انحاء مصر وبدا معها
ظهور اسم اللواء محمد البطران مدير مباحث
قطاع السجون بعد نجاحه عشيه الثامن
والعشرين من يناير في منع خروج المساجين
من سجن الفيوم
صباح السبت التاسع والعشرين تلقى بلاغا
بوجود تمرد في سجن القطر وهناك تلقى رصاصه
قاتله
تلك الرصاصه التي
تحياته وفتحت الباب واسعا امامنا للسعي
نحو اجابات
لاسئله اهمها من قتل اللواء البطران
مثلت جريمه اغتيال اللواء البطران
الصندوق الاسود لعمليات فتح السجون
واقتحامها
ولكي نصل الى الحقيقه
كان علينا ان تتبع خيوط الدم التي تشير
الى القتله في محاوله للكشف عن الحقيقه
[موسيقى]
يحاول فريق العمل في هذا الفيلم الامساك
بالخيط من اوله لاستجلاء الحقيقه الغائبه
او الحقيقه التي يحاول اللجنه بنصها
ولنبدا مع رحله البحث من اولها
اخر محادثات نيه بيني وبين الله المطران
اه كانت يوم السبت
29 يناير الساعه 9 من يوم
اغتيال
اليوم اللي قبله كانت جمعه الغضب اللي شيء
غير الارسال فيها كان مقطوع مش عارفين
فانا اليوم السبت 9 ونص الصبح انا كلمته
في مكتبه علشان الط من عليه عمري في حياتي
ما شفت اخويا
متنرفز ومعصب
اليوم بدا بكلمه بيقول محمد طمني عليك كان
بيصرخ واللي العادلي حرق البلد العدلي حرق
البلد العدل
قررت ثلاث مرات
وساعتها يقول ياتي ماتعرفيش اللي حصل في
18 اسم ا تفتحوا في القاهره والبلطجيه
والمساجين طلعوا من الاسلام دين قطع الطرق
شكرا الخيمه بيزرعوا الناس الذهاب بيطرحه
المحافظ والساعات
الناس السابق والمطالب اللي داخله حصل في
السجون المصريه حصل فيها كافه انا استحاله
اسمح بكده استحاله
في المكتبه
بالاحداث
العسكري
اللي سابق ال الثوابت محمد
اه
الاداري اللي محمد مستنيك الاساس اذا كان
التعليم في الاخبار
اللي والله الخارج النهار ده
اللي هو المفترض ان النهار ده بس الظروف
البلد
اصبحت الشعب ولا حتى يوم الاجازه قال لي
حتى
والاغرب من كده
واشوف الاولاد وعند الثانيه الساعه سته
الصبح اه في المصلحه طبعا هو
طالع ان موجه المطار عشان مسافه نكمل
دراستنا
انا بقول لي ساعات
راح فين اليوم لا يحسن تخاف عليه والقران
عليكم
قال لي العمر واحد والرب واحد
[موسيقى]
ساهمت اجهزه الاتصالات الحديثه في الثوره
المصريه بنصيب وافر فقد استطاعت كاميرات
الهواتف المحموله ان تسجل احداث ا ستظل
محفوره في الذاكره المصريه والعالميه اذ
تم تسجيل هروب السجناء من عدد كبير من
سجون مصر صوتا وصوره بما يفتح مجالا
للتاويل ان القائمين على السجون قد يفسح
طريق الهروب امام اه
لكن ال اه اعلاميه اخرى قد استطاعت ان
تشكك في هذه الادله لين فتح الطريق امام
تفسيرات مختلفه لما حدث تدعي احداها تنظيم
السجناء عمليه الهروب الجماعي بينما تدعي
الاخرى ان وزاره الداخليه هي من افصحت
الطريقه واسعا امام هم للهروب
نفسها
العظيم وجاء السلاح وهي كتاب الله
تلقى اللواء محمد البطران بلاغا يفيد
بحدوث تمر وهي في سجن القطع الجديد الذي
يبعد حوالي اربعين كيلومترا عن القاهره
ويضم بين جدران الزنازين اكثر من اربعه
الاف وخمسمائه تسجيل
فتوجه الى السجن على الفور
احد الاصدقاء صديق محبوس في القطاع
على انه يحصل كذا وكذا في سجن القطع وان
هناك اشخاص داخل السجن معهم تليفون
استطاعوا تهريب وعايزين اتصل بيك وابلغوا
اللي بيحصل
[موسيقى]
وهو من اهل المنطقه اه اللي اه
اللي
والضرب
انا سالت
العربيه
فيما يتعلق بوزاره الداخليه حول وقعت مقتل
اللواء البطران
انهم صراحه في كل الجرائد الرسميه ان
اللواء محمد البطران رئيس مباحث
الفيوم
الفيوم المركزي على
وهذه ال واقعه غير صحيح بالمره اللي هو
الان في السجن الاقصى وان اللواء البطران
مساعد وزير الداخليه ورئيس مباحث قطاع
السجون ما هواش الرئيس مباحث الفيوم
بعد ساعات قليله من اصابته تاكدت وفاه
اللواء محمد عباس البطران رئيس مباحث قطاع
السجون في مصر وتم دفنه صباح الثلاثين من
يناير كانون الثاني عام الفين واحد عشر
في مقابر الاسره ب نزله البطران في الهرم
بدون معاينه من النيابه او تشريح لل جثمان
او تصريح بالدخل او اجراء تحقيق في الواقع
من وزاره الداخليه
وكاد دمه ان يضيع سدى
واوشكت الحقيقه ان تدفن معه لولا ان توجهت
شقيقته بهذا البلاغ البلاغ رقم الف ومائه
بلغتنا العام لسنه 2011
تم تعيين المستشار لجعفر بالنيابه العامه
على الشان التحيه في القضيه
يعني زي ما تقول وامن الاول كده اول
القصيده كفر عنوان البلاغ الطب في مكتب
النائب العام التحقيق فى واقعه مقتل
اللواء محمد البطران رئيس مباحث سجن
الفيوم
للمستشار اللي هو الجعفر قلت له اللي هو
البطران رئيس مباحث سجن الفيوم
عليها
بدات التحقيقات فى واقعه مقتل اللواء
البطران في السادس عشر من فبراير شباط عام
الفين واحد عشر تلك التحقيقات التي
استطعنا الوصول اليها ويعتمد عليها فريق
البحث استدعى قاضي التحقيق الرائد احمد
مجدي الذي رافق اللواء البطران الى السجن
وصاحبه داخل عن ابره ورافقه مصابا في
سياره الاسعاف الى المستشفى
ودارت وقائع التحقيق
[تصفيق]
ما هي طبيعه عملك تحديدا انا ضابط لقسم ال
عمليات البحث الجنائي الاخت ام
ماهي علاقتك الوظيفيه بالسيد اللواء محمد
البطران هو رئيس قسم من البحث الجنائي
بالقطاع وهو يعتبر رئيس المباشر و لحوالي
سبع سنين شغل ما متى تلقيت تحديدا البلاغ
حدوث حاله
حوالي الساعه 10 صباحا و توصلتم تحديدا
الى سجن القطع بعد حوالي اربعين غياب عدم
تلقيها ما هي كيفيه انتقال
بسياره الشغله حضرت ال بتاعه محمد بن
المطران ما الذي حدث فور وصولهم الى سيدي
القاضي لما وصلنا الى السبب دخلنا الى
عنبر المساجين في حول الاستراليه لعدم
الرجل ومنا بدخول بعض الامل الا انه في
حوالي الساعه ثلاثه ونص حاول المساجين
الخروج محادثه اصابه محمد البطران واللي
ادت
هكذا يقرر الرائد احمد مجدي في شهادته انه
لم يكن موجودا في السجن اثناء اصابه
اللواء البطران بينما جاء في شهاده الجندي
سابق ان احمد مجدي لم يغادر السجن بالاساس
ما قولك فيما قرره سالف الذكر ا ما جاء في
شهاده الجنان احمد مجدي لم يغادر السجن
بالاساس
ما قولك فيما قرره سالف الذكر امر سابق
جاء في شهاده الجنان احمد مجدي بيريز
بالاساس
ما قولك فيما لم يغادر سالف الذكر ا ما
جاء في شهاده الجندي سابق ان احمد مجدي
بيريس جانبا لا س ما قولك فيما لم يغادر
سالف الذكر ا ما جاء في شهاده الجندي سابق
ان احمد مجدي بيريس جانبا لا س ما قولك
فيما لم يغادر سالف الذكر امس
السابق ان احمد مجدي
بالاساس ما قولك في مكه انا كنت عائد من
المستشفى الطلبين بالذات منطقه السبوع
وحين الوصول الى باب السجن شهدت خرج جميع
من كانوا بداخله مما دفعنا خلفا وشهدت
بعدها مباشره اللواء محمد البطران في ناس
بمبادره حاله وجود على ثلاث الامن ومحاوله
المساكين انا كنت با المصابين والمتوفين
شبه الجديد الى مستشفى سجن الافضل القديمه
ما هي كيفيه نقل كل هؤلاء المصابين
والمتوفين ان كنت بركه معهم عربيه بتاعه
الموضوع ال كنت تقوم بنقل المصابين
والمتوفين الم فرديه انا كنت موجود مع
في نفس الوقت الفين سواء سميرات في
العربيه الخاصه ب اللواء محمد البطران
طوقت السجن ولاحظ ان العربيه بتاعت ال ان
شاء الله مره واحده وما كان فيه حد السواء
ظل الرائد احمد نجده داخل السجن اولا فتره
بقاء اللواء محمد البطران بالداخل ايوه هو
هو هو الحد ما خرج خرجوا كلهم وبعدين خرج
محمد بتعود هل تلاحظ لك وجود ثمه عربيه
اسعاف بالمكان هي عربيه واحده بس دخلت
وخرج الثاني الخرج تلك السياره بعد ان
اصطحبت ثمه اشخاص بداخلها انا انا ما شفتش
كان فيها ناس هل كان يوجد ثمه اشخاص بجوار
قائدها انا انا شفت السواء بس
في حد ثاني جمر ما هو عدد مرات دخول وخروج
تلك السيارات من والى السجن هي مره واحده
بس دخلت وخرجت ان اين كان الرائد احمد
نجدي وقت اصابه اللواء محمد البطران هو
كان كويس وكيف وقفت على ذلك لان احمد به
مجدي هو اللي وصلوا لحد العربيه ولكن مع
الاسف كمان قاعده الحد يعني بعد ما ثمنطاش
وامعانا بعدما مات محمد
الوقت قال لي انا طبعا اللي وقع العاجل ان
شاء الله وبيناته
خايفين بيقولوا احنا شفناه علشان طبعا
فكانوا خايفين يتكلم
لكن هل كان واعرف وكل حاجه
حاول فريق عمل الفيلم الذهاب الى سجن
القطع لاستجلاء اي معلومات يمكن ان تقدم
اضافه جديده في رحله البحث لكننا واجهنا
صعوبه بالغه في الاقتراب من محيط السجن
الذي يعتبر واحدا من السجون شديده الحراسه
حيث يقع في الصحراء الى الشمال الغربي من
مدينه القاهره كما تحيط به اعداد كبيره من
حقول الالغام اضافه الى اكمله الشرطه
اهم الشهاده في القضيه
جلال رئيس مباحث سجن
الجديد وكان مرافق اللواء البطران واصيب
في تاخذ
ال كنت متواجدا برفقه المرحوم محمد
البطران داخل السجن القتل الجديد حال حدوث
اصابته التي اودت بحياته
لا سببوا تواجد كما بالمكان والزمان
احنا كنا عرب المسؤولين من داخل السجن
ومتى تم الاتصال اللواء محمد البطران
انا
الوصول
الى داخل
[موسيقى]
علينا الان ان جمد المشهد قليلا حيث يمثل
المكان الذي قتل فيه اللواء البطران نقطه
كبير
ما هو مكان تواجد تحديدا واللواء محمد
البطران وقت احد و في اصابه كل من كما
احنا كنا بمبارتين المكاتب المؤدي للبوابه
العموميه بداخل السفر اي بوابه يقصدها
المقدم سيد جلال نشاهد في الصور المعروضه
حاليا
تمثيلا بالحادثه طبقا الصور التي التقطتها
اللجنه المكلفه من قبل اداره البحث
الجنائي كما رواها المقدم سيد جلال
وهي تظهر ان اطلاق النار عليه هو وال لواء
البتراء قد وقع اثناء تواجدهما داخل هذا
المبنى وبين ب وابديه المغلقتين حيث لم
يكن معهما احد
من كان برفقه كما انذاك من رجال الشرطه في
نفس اللحظه كانت حادثه
تشير وقائع التحقيق الى مفاجئه اخرى فقد
تم استجواب المقدم سيد جلال مره اخرى من
قبل محقق اخر بعد ثلاثه اشهر وجاءت شهادته
الثانيه مناقضه تماما
بشهادته الاولى
من كان متواجدا بين البوابتين بخلاف كما
انت واللواء البقر ان وقت حدوث اصابه كما
كما ان المقدم سمعه العربي وكان داخل معنا
مجموعه من المسؤولين دول يظلم على
بالاضافه ولمجموعه اخرى كانت تجري محاوله
الخروج السريع
تناقض ت الشهادتان للسيد جلال ولم يبدو
ذلك كافيا لان يلفت انتباه من يتولى
التحقيق الى معرفه اسباب ذلك هو ذكر في
الشوط الاول انه هو كان موجود هو سياده
اللواء محمد البطران في مبنى التنفيذ
العقابي وهو ما الواحد يوم وهذا يتناقض مع
الاخوان وبردو بعد ثلاث شهور ما قد لي
بنفسه وشهاده اخرى
قال ان هو كان موجود
اللي البطرك والمقدم اسامه العوضى وبعض
المسؤولين
والان يدخل في الصوره شاهد جديد بشهاده
تؤكد ما قاله سيد جلال في الشهاده الثانيه
اين كنت موجودا لحظه اطلاقه الكبير انا
كنت داخل من التنفيذ العقابي ومن الذي كان
معك في هذه الاونه اه لكن معايا اللواء
محمد البطران والمقدمه خلال
لماذا تطوع المقدم اسامه العوضى للادلاء
بشهاده تؤكد وجوده في موقع الحدث
معززا شهاده السيد جلال الثانيه
علينا الان ان نتابع جزء اخر من شهاده سيد
جلال ما هو السبب الذي يؤدي اليه وفاه
المرحوم اللواء محمد البطران و اصابك من
جراء اطلاق العراقيه التي تم اطلاقها
للحيلوله دون هروب المسيء ومن اي الابراج
اطلقت هذه الاعيره و وما احتمال برج من
الابراج رقم واحد اثنين ثلاثه على اساس ان
هذه الابراج بتواجه مبنى تنفيذ العقاب
اللي لا ت وقع فيه الحادث
هل يمكنك تحديد اي من الابراج ثلاثه اصابه
المجنى عليه المرحوم اللواء محمد البطران
لان كل الابراج تطلق الاعيره الناريه وكنا
في حاله هياج شديد ولا استطيع ان اجزم عن
اي من اين اتت اصابه المرحوم محمد
ويمكن حدوثها من اي من الا بثلاثين بينما
في الشهاده نفسها يقول اين كان اللواء
محمد البطران يقف تحديدا عند ندائه عليك
اه هو كان يقف بالقرب من البوابه التي بها
المسبعات الحريري هل كان يقف في مدى اطلاق
النار الخاص بالبرجين 1 و 2 لا هو لم يكن
ثمار واحده هل يمكن حدوث اصابه من النيران
التي كانت تطلق من البرجين واحد واثنين
وكيف ذلك لان الطلقات اه ممكن ترتيب الدور
بعد عبورها من البوابه الحديديه والزرقاء
وتعمل لو سكتور ما ومن ثم ترتد من
تصطدم بجسم الله
طبعا علميا لا يجوز لان انا بس يكون
واحد فرقه صغيره
اعرف يعني اه على حافه المصروفات فلما
يكون الغزو بيروح على كثير ما بتقول له
قوته
وفقدانه قدره على اللي يخترق
انا في الحقيقه وما في العالم لكن التفسير
العلمي والصحيح ان الطاقات من البورده رقم
ثلاثه
والمرحله
في الوقت الذي يفترض فيه المقدم سيد جلال
امكانيه الاصابه من احد البرجين واحد او
اثنين يؤكد شهود عيان من السجناء ان
الرصاصه جاءت من البرج رقم ثلاثه
في هذه الحاله من الطبيعي ان تظهر اسئله
جديده امام فريق البحث من كان يقف في
البرج رقم ثلاثه وهل اصيب اللواء البطران
عن طريق الخطا كما يقول الضباط والجنود ام
كانت اصابته متعمده في خضم التحقيق في هذه
القضيه الخطيره يتقدم احد السجناء بشهاده
شديده الاهميه كان لابد لها ان تغير مجرى
التحقيقات
انا شفت محمد به البترا
وبعدين
واشاره للجهاد حلاوه عشان يضرب نار او هو
ضرب نار من فول بورد محمد بين انصار السيد
جلال ومساجين كرست ان ينال
الشهاده واضحه جدا اشارت ضابط عصام البصره
مامور سجن القطا الجديد الى الرائد جهاد
حلاوه الذي كان يحتل البرج رقم ثلاثه
وبحوزته بندقيه اليه اطلق منها النار على
اللواء المطران فارداه قتيلا واصاب المقدم
سيد جلال فمن هو جهاد حلاوه ومن هو عصام
البصره قبل ان نستمع الى اقوالهما علينا
ان نسعى الى هذه الملاحظه الغريبه التي
سبقت التحقيق مع الضابطين المتهمين
تضاربت شهادات شهود الاثنين ضباط المتهمين
ضربت الزاي يعني اه اه الضابط الاول ال
اسمح لك اه اه انا ما كنت موجود
حلاوه كان في البرج رقم ثلاثه على وقال لا
انا كنت با السور بتمشي
البصره
جئنا بانه في تحقيق النيابه قاعد في نفس
الغرفه اللي بيتحقق فيها مع الضابط حلاوه
تاخذ اقوالهم علي نون شهور و على سبيل
الاستدلال
واعادوا مع بعض يخالف القانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه حتى لو مشهود لا يجوز الماده
مائه واثنا عشر اللي بتقول يجمع القاضي كل
شاهد على حده على الفرار ولو ان يواجه
الشهود بعضهم بعض
المتهمين
يبقى هنا في التحقيق وفي تواطؤ التحرير
ما هي طبيعه عمل تحديدا
في
محاوله الحرب
ما هي الاجراءات التي اتخذتها ادارته
بالنصح والارشاد لكن
بالخارج
انا كنت
على المسؤولين داخل السجن
بعد بحث طويل
استطعنا الوصول الى احد شهود العيان
الذي كان يقضي عقوبه داخل السجن اثناء
الاحداث واصبح الان حره وقد رفض ظهور وجهه
على الشاشه يقرر شاهدنا الجديد عكس ما
يقوله الرائد جهاد حلاوه ويؤكد انه شاهده
معطل يا البرج رقم ثلاثه يطلق الرصاص
اه انطلب علينا خرطوش ال ال مفتش المباحث
وان طلب المساعده الدموع لحد ما وصل اللي
هو المطران اه المسؤولين نقلها او مشرفات
وطبعا راح عليه اه عايزين
نمشي الوساطه فعلا
العنابر يعني النووي يمشي على الاداره
البرج اللي قدم البوابه
كانت حلاوه لكن ما بحث عن من العطاء
السمو العسكري
هل كنت متواجدا بالسجن وقت حدوث اصابه
اللواء البطران لا انا كنت في السجن
القديم
برفقه عبد المجيد مصطفى احمد اسماعيل اليس
من الغريب ان يترك العميد عصام البصره
موقعه في السجن في وقت حرج كهذا تجري فيه
محاوله للهرب حيث يتواجد اللواء البطران
رئيس مباحث مصلحه السجون
بينما ياتي جهاد حلاوه من السجن المجاور
ويعتلي البرج ويطلق الرصاص
ما تعليقك م ما قرره سالف الذكر ايضا لان
المساجين مش بيحبوني وكان عندهم مخطط
للاعتداء عليه يومها وبيحاولوا ينالوا مني
باي شكل
تحصل تضرب المساجين بالعمر
انا اقول لك الحقيقه
بعد شوايا
الموصل انا عصام
على عصابه
كمسؤول
محمد بالبترول واصابه هو مضمون الحوار
الذي دار بين اللواء محمد البطران ضابط
يعصى البصره قبل حدوث اصابه الاول هو
قالوا ايه اللي انت عامل تضرب المساجين
بال نرجو العنابر اللي
التحقيق في نفس
فيما قرره السجين اسم احمد ابو ساده
التحقيقات الكلام ده فتره واللي حصل انا
قلت ان وهي الاقصى المنطقه انت نفيت اهداف
الاطلاق اللي اه اه اللي هو البطل ان وهو
طبعا موجود في الداخل اللي معه سلاحه
انه يعني حاولت
او كذا لانه من احد تعليمات السجون انه
فيه
السجناء وهو مسلحه عشان سراح من مجمل
التحقيق لن يواجه اي اتهام لاي حد القصور
في التحقيق او التواطؤ بالمحاق
اه لان ده قضيه قتل عمد مع سبق الاصرار
والشهود موجوده وفي شهود اخرين وفي
الاهداف لو الموصل لاقى ان
التناقض بعض الشهود وعدم
عدم وجود بعضيهم ومواجهه الاحداث كلها
يفيد
من المحقق سواء كان تحقيقا ونيابه وفي
تواطؤ من الضباط مع بعضيهم على اساس ان
الداخليه لها يد في هذا الموضوع
يسجل تقرير المنظمه المصريه للحقوق
الشخصيه
معلومات موثقه عن ما جرى في السجون
المصريه
وبصفه خاصه في سجن القطع يتضمن التقرير
عددا من الحقائق حول ما جرى من احداث اتنا
في تصريحات الداخليه المصريه كما يوثق
التقرير اسماء واعداد المتوفين والجرحى من
المساجين وبما يتفق مع الروايات التي
شاهدناها بالصوت والصوره
ومعروف عن الناس والمسافه اللي كانت بين
البرق والمكان كان واقفين حوالي ثمانيه
يعني معروف ال
الطرفين يعني بعد شوي شوي يعني كل المشاهد
اللي فيديوهات اللي هي جات لها من خلال
الكارثه ومن خلال الوزراء داخل السجن
ووفقنا ها
اثبات
في القضيه اليوم محمد البطران وطلبنا من
السجون
باسماء المساجين اللي موجودين في العنابر
اللي في الفتره اللي
واسماء
الاملاء اللي كانوا موجودين وباسم اسرائيل
الكرام موجودين الان الاداره اللي عم
لمصلحه سجون يعني يعني ما شاء الله
تحركت تحديدا الموقف من مقتل اللواء
البطران
ومحاوله اه اه اه يعني تغطيه على الحادث
يعني مسائل تتكلم على رئيس مباحث لمصر اه
اه فيدفن من غير ما تم تشريح الجثت يوميا
كانت اول جلسه مع قوات التحيات
والايطالي حضرتك
[موسيقى]
واحنا لازم نعمل شيء والنيابه العامه على
ورقه التحيات بتقول انه الاسره رفض
التشريح
الشر وهذا لم يحدث
وبعد مرور اكثر من اربعه اشهر يحدث تحول
جديد في القضيه اذ تقرر ندب الطب الشرعي
لاستخراج جثه المجنى عليه اللواء محمد
البطران
لتشريحها وبيان الاصابات التى لحقت بها
والاداه المستخدمه في احداثها
وموقف الضارب من المعروف بعدا
واتجاها ومستوى حددوا يوم ثلاثين يوميا
للطب الشرعي
لجنه من الطب الشرعي مع التحقيقات مع
مساعد مدير امن مع مجموعه من سكنه من
الاسم القرن واحنا هناك المقبره وفتح
المقترح اللي كان التربيه اللي بيفتحوا
المقبره انا لقيت هم عاملين يقول والله
انا صار لي عندنا باه بقيت انا مش نحنا
ايه اللي بيقولوا الواحد او المره ابقى في
الموقف حياتي
[موسيقى]
الطبيه
الطبيب الشرعي ذكر في تقريره ان تطلق جايه
من مكان مرتفع
رحله من اعلى الى اسفل
اخترقت التمويل الامام الجنسي ودخلت على
الضلع السادس بخسارته كان منافسه اليوم
التالي من الرصد يعني معنى ذلك انه
انطلاقا ومباشره لفلسفه كرمه ولا في اي
كلام من دليل كرمه غير قادره طبقا العلم
معروفات او علميا لا يجوز
دفن اللواء البطران بدون تشريح بجثمانه
وقد القى ذلك بظلال من الشك حول طبيعه
اصابته وعدد الرصاصات التي اخترقت جسده
وبعد محاولات عده وجدنا عن دعم حامد
الترابي الذي دفن الجثمان واخرجه من
مراقبه ليتم تشريحه مزيدا من الحيره
والغموض
[موسيقى]
شويه في الخلف
لا يتضمن تقرير الطبيب الشرعي استخراج اي
رصاصات من جثمان البطران بينما يقرر عن
حامد الترابي انه قد تم استخراج عدد من
الرصاصات من الجسم ان
وهنا تنشا علامه استفهام جديده وقد حاول
فريق البحث الاتصال مرارا بمصلحه الطب
الشرعى لاكثر من شهر بدون جدوى حيث كنا
نحتاج الى من يحل لنا لغز الرصاصات التي
يمكن ان تكون قد اختفت من جسد البطران ومن
تقرير الطبيب الشرعي
[موسيقى]
من المؤكد ان اللواء البطران قد قتل لكن
هل كان القتل عمدا
ام كان عن طريق الخطا
لكي نصل الى اجابه هذا السؤال توجهنا الى
مدينه السويس لنلتقي بالحاجه على الجنين
احد اعضاء لجنه تقصى الحقائق حول احداث
الثوره
بالنسبه لل او برونك ملف القضيه اللواء
البطران لا تمام لا برافو فانا عقدها
الامن الذين تقصي الحقائق
وشغلهم
وافتكر انهم يتوصلوا الى معلومات جديه
لتؤكد موضوع البطل ان تم استهدافها
بعض العناصر
شهد شاهد من اهلها الدكتور اللواء عبد
اللطيف البديني مساعد وزير الداخليه تلك
الشهاده التي ادلى بها امام قاضي التحقيق
وعندما القينا عليه تساؤلاتنا لم يتردد في
الاجابه التي تمليها عليه خبرته وضميره
اللواء البطران الرصاصه السلاح الضربه
سلاح يعني يصلح مثلا يعني سلاح قناص
السلاح بيضرب دفعه او حاجه لا ده كان
بيضرب طلقه طلقه عم اه
كان المقصود به هو اللي البطران لان اللي
بيضرب طلقه انا استخدم اسلوب التنشين مش
اسلوب ال ال الضرب العشوائي
على جانب اخر وفي مقابله مع قناه الجزيره
يصرح عمر مروان امين عام لجنه تقصي
الحقائق
تصريحا يستند الى التقرير الاول مؤكدا ان
اللواء البطران قد قتل عن طريق الخطا
برصاص الشرطه
باختصار اه اللواء البطران شخصيه محبوبه
ورجل محترم حتى المساجين كانت بتحب فهو
لما كان فيه تمرد في سجن الارضي انتقل
اليه عشان يهدد من المسيحيين وبعدما اه
استطاع ان ينجز مهمته هو خارج من الباب
دفعه بعض المساجين للهروب من الباب من
وراء
الابراج اطلقت النار على المساكين
الذين يحاولون الفراغ اصيب اللواء البطران
بطاقتين واصيب مامور السجن الطلقه واصيب
بعض المسؤولين
يعني الحقيقه يعني قتل خطا
لم يكن قتل متعمد من احد اهم الاحداث
بيقول انه هو لجنه تقصي الحقائق الاولى
لما تشكلت المستشار عمر مروان قال ان
النووي البطران قتل عن طريق الخطا ولكن
الحقيقه ان التقرير وموجود وعند كل الناس
لم يشر الى ان اللغه الكتل عن طريق الخطا
التقرير قال مجموعه من المساجين
والمسؤولين بيقولوا اللي حصل انه البطل
الضرب على بالنار
لكن ما لم يذكر ان اللي والبطن عن طريق
الخطا
اه طبعا اه ال له البطر انما كانت ش جزء
من المؤامره التي اه صيغه لفتح السجون قال
ان الرجل الواقف بكل وطنيه وكل شهامه
يدافع عن هذا الامر البغيض الذي يعلم علم
اليقين انه سيؤدي الى انفلات امني لا طاقه
للبلاد
وكان عمر قتلوا انا اعتقد اه امر يعني
متوقع ثم حفظ الملف
وكان شيء متعمد لاحظوا ملف اكل اللغه
البطر ام لانه هاي الدين
القيادات الموجوده في الداخليه كان لها
دور في البصره
[موسيقى]
اتهمت الدكتوره منال البطران الضابطين
جهاد حلاوه و عصام البصراطى بقتل شقيقه
اللواء محمد البطران في بلاغ الى النائب
العام فهل يمكن ان تقدم الداخليه ادله
ادانه رجالها
للاسف الشديد من يوم ما اخوي اضرب بالنار
من يوم 9 يناير لحد ما تعمل معينه لكن
الاخطر في تسعه وعشرين مليون يعني احنا
بنتكلم على اربع شهور ال اربع شهور دي في
الفتره دي اما اخفاء ادله اللي تجمع بعد
اسبوع او اثنين وادى للخ ص صفه الحك الحكم
يعني اذا كان الان بكده هم رجال الشرطه او
او او
عملاء النظام اه السابق حبيب حبيب العدلي
هو حسني مبارك قاعد اليهم لجمع الادله وهم
مرتكبي الجرائم عدم تقديم اثر كاد ان احد
الله عز وجل الداخليه سواء السبيل كل
القضايا الصوره احد من هذا المعنى واحد بس
انه ثلاثه الداخليه مسيطر عليها من ذات
النظام الامد ضد الصوره وهو لمنتخب
الجرائم هو اللي بيحقق فيها الجريمه حضرتك
نفسه يعني حيقدر نفسه متهم في جريمه هو
عملها في هذه القضيه حصل حجب للادله من ان
تصل الى هذه المحطه يعني كان في المحقق
بيطلب ال ال في قضيه من الاجهزه الامنيه
النوتيه بتيجي التحريات بصوره من طبعا
معروف من الشرطه في التحريات متطابقه مع
الروايه اللي جايه من السجن بمعنى قيمه
الحلقه امام المحقق انه لا مجال امامه الا
ان يامر بغلق التحقيق لانه ما فيش فيها اه
ادله كثيره
ام
انا في النهايه بقول بعد كل العذاب اللي
الواحد شافوا اذا كان اللواء البطران اللي
هو مساعد وزير الداخليه ورئيس مباحث قطاع
السجون
انا مش عارف الحرب
وكل التسويف اللي عم بيحصل في هذا القضاء
المصري طيب الشهداء اللي بيته من اول ما
بدات الصوره المصريه والناس الغلبه يعني
بعد ان قيدت ضد مجهول
لا تزال قضيه مقتل البطران تراوح في
مكانها
فلم يتم توجيه الاتهام الى اي من الضباط
المتهمين الذين لا يزالون في مواقعهم
الا انها وبعد عام من اغلاقها تعيد محكمه
جنايات الجيزه فتح التحقيقات في القضيه
مره اخرى
ويتولاها قاضي تحقيقات جديد لن ظل على
حالنا بين خوف من سطو في الضلال و رجاء
الوصول الى ان كان هذه القضيه تمثل خطا
احمر ضمن خطوط حمراء كثيره لم يسمح لاحد
تجاوزها
ام